now on our first trip as an official
presidential candidate to Iowa Carly
Fiorina former New York Governor George
Pataki wisconsin Governor Scott Walker
Rick Santorum former Maryland Governor
Martin O'Malley Ohio Governor John
Kasich a senator Bernie Sanders in Texas
senator Ted Cruz sir I cut out the first
Christy publican presidential candidate
South Carolina senator and moonlighting
stand-up comedian Lindsey Graham's a lot
of people have come and said I didn't
know who you were but you know the
wonderful thing is you know like I was
in the airport yesterday on the way here
sitting down lady comes up to me she
says I'm a staunch Democrat but I love
you that's pretty good that's good that
could be ben Carson slow college
democrats love me do you ever though
have to actually live on your paycheck
as a temp person at the end of every
week you know I would have maybe five
cents in the checking account I remember
needing to rent an apartment and the
landlord asking me well how much money
is in your checking account and I wrote
down fifty dollars because that was true
so i have lived paycheck to pay so
what's different this time what's
different is the country has been in
stagnation four more years I've
recognized what the core that problem is
and we have an economic platform that's
going to not only unite America but win
this election using an arbitrary number
which is exactly what national polls are
two divided candidates in any way is not
in the best interest of getting the
right candidate to run it's not it's not
a matter about me or anybody else it's a
matter about the people of America and
the people in the early primary States
you're going to be paying most attention
to have this chance to opportunity to
see everybody in a so again senator
bernie sanders thanks for making time
for us this evening center centers
significant you'll never go to forgive
me for that are you I'm not you might
mine either with my cardiologist we got
to lift the restrictions you've got
people who could draw in air strikes
with laser-guided components as air
controllers who could be doing the job
to help the Allies that we have that the
Sunnis the Kurds and others we're not
lifting those restrictions I think
that's an important extent I like Marco
Rubio obviously I'm deferential to
governor's I think there's a lot it's we
bring to the table as having proving
Beckett of experience but i do like
marco rubi i think he and i have similar
thoughts and national defense and
foreign policy overall like him and I
like the fact that you brought you saw
you probably comment on this that when
it was his birthday I send a nice little
tweet saying Marco happy birthday from
140 something to another just first talk
about your mother who died of Hodgkin's
disease what was that like she thought
man I tell you she wanted to live so bad
she got sick like I saying sometime in
the fall of 75 and going through
chemotherapy and when you got a family
member is in a bad way you want a will
well I mean you don't want to give up
god no she didn't want to give up Easter
that Easter and 76 she had her best
Easter she was feeling good and she
cooked dinner for the first time in a
long time it's just the four of you
other family yeah now there's some
family at first but neaten it was just
us set me on the couch and and I
remember saying well boy I gave you a
good dinner didn't I said yes ma'am you
did and you know so we thought maybe you
know maybe we're going to be the one
percent here and by June she was gone a
couple calls to people who were my close
friends and I said by the way I was
thinking this morning about something
and I
kind of made a decision nation for what
I said I've decided I'm gonna run for
president tonight is done they burn star
what happened I think sometimes people
just they just don't understand you know
they some people known becomes for 20
years ago and they're commenting who i
am today and you know I'm not who I was
20 years ago I like to I was 20 years
ago but I like Who I am now and you know
everything was fine and no big gyrations
know it just was good I enjoyed it you
know what I was really fun to deliver
the talk and to have so many people do
that's what's kind of little bit over
where do you think we are now let's tell
you where you are but where are we as a
country do you think on this question of
what is worth sending American men and
women overseas to fight for who one of
the things that preceded the failure of
the nation state of Syria the rise of
Isis was he effective climate change and
the mega drought that affected that
region wiped out farmers drove people
the city's created a humanitarian crisis
they created the symptoms or rather the
the conditions of extreme poverty that
is led now to do the rise of ice on this
extreme violence so the pandemic in West
Africa there are many instances where
we're behind the rating the turning
radius the crisis are left with only
military responses want some lips up and
becomes too great and I'm not asking to
repudiate Donald Trump as a person I
don't think you're as good friends with
them as some of the other people erase
you have been critical so I just I'm to
understand what separates you from the
others who have been feel this is sort
of beyond the pale I'm not going to
engage in the media's game of bashing
another Republican candidate I'm just
not gonna do some people say the reason
you're not doing and you have a big
threat from his previous comments is
because you want to make sure that he
does get out of the race you're able to
win the supporters that he has is this a
political calculation I am NOT going to
go into the gutter with personal attacks
and impugning character now let me be
clear i do think policy distinctions are
fair game so i will talk about
differences whether it is on amnesty or
common core or religious liberty or
marriage or life or any other issue
that's what's supposed to be the bread
and butter of politics but i'm not going
to
personal attacks impugning anyone elses
carrots what Hillary Clinton be worse on
the economy than Barack Obama are you
think about the same if we can just take
some anecdotal snapshots if doubling the
capital gains tax is worse than Barack
Obama so in that case i would say worse
Bloomberg's Jennifer Epstein asked
Clinton about her position on the
Keystone pipeline well Jen thank you for
that you know no other presidential
candidate was Secretary of State when
this process started and I put together
a very thorough deliberative
evidence-base process to evaluate the
environmental impact and other
considerations of Keystone so I will
refrain from commenting because I had a
leading role in getting that process
started and I think that we have to let
it run its course do you have a goal
tonight except one all 1,200 people
including Hillary Clinton supporters to
come out and put on my pits that is my
girl you're gone all right go it's okay
it's a lot of the goal that's horrible
so just go back to the nervous thing
when you get nervous what happens I got
louder louder hazel mega punches so you
might do the monster on skazal Iceland I
was shocked when I saw given the choice
between Bruce Springsteen i'm jon bon
jovi that you sided with jon bon jovi if
you had to choose between Bruce
Springsteen bonds or not their music or
choose between them well then a short
shorts Jon Jon's become a friend yeah
over over the last few years and so and
Bruce I have a cordial relationship with
we know each other we've worked on some
things together but John and Dorothea
have become friends of mine and Mary
Patsy so maritime I answered it the same
way even though I've been to a hundred
and twenty four verse Springsteen shows
and i think i've been to four bon jovi
shows so from a music respective versus
in my history played but John's become a
friend but i'll ask you to question that
desert island discs right if you were
going to an island
only take the catalog of one or the
other which is a catalog you can take
the catalog or one of the other you pick
spring supervisor bring steam the
question is whether Santorum can do
better than Romney did on this set at
the national sport of Iowa which is bags
so senator we're gonna give you a shot
at this and we also talked to you about
some politics while you do it okay so
first let's see how you do here asking
to shut whoa give me to hold a lot you
might want to just say that okay thank
you all very much goodnight way back
artsy just you just held a press
availability while eating pork I'm
wondering if you'll commit as president
have all your press conference is why
you tile of work that would be fun
governor you have any tattoos don't know
what's up do you ever get close no but I
can remember Denver getting elected one
vote at a time is that a challenge 330
million people that too jealous for sure
but this is how you win an Iowa
seven people one-on-one retail love it
in you got to be here helicopter in
leave you got to be all in he gave out
my cell phone number on national
television so I had fun with it and at
the end of the day we'll get serious
this is the silly season your monster
invitation can you get